what time and night does this thing  start a dish know was probably we're on  1111 all heard that Lee yeah I could  never be I wouldn't have to sleep three  hours earlier early-bird Swing joke so  you get there and are people walking  around in their clothing or they knew at  first everybody's clothes right like you  know women are in sexy outfits how would  you assess the women where they tens  were they fives with what were they I  would say it's five or six to attend to  no there was no nobody there that was  terrible and you're saying there were  tens there yeah oh all day not as 100 or  out of ten  oh when you're there do you in terms of  the men how did the men look on a scale  of one to ten are there tens there as  well yeah yeah there are where are you  on that yeah I'm just curious because  I'm actually in really good shape right  now go ahead I'm probably about a seven  right Chuy's are two so respect that